make videos in your car that actually is
one of the best environments to make
videos simply your car actually is like
an audio Booth you know when it's kind
of noisy outside there's lots of road
noise and then you close the door to
your car and it's like boom calm quiet
secondly it is actually pretty good
lighting cuz if it's the day time you've
got light coming in but it's kind of
softened a little bit if you're not like
actually having direct sunlight hitting
you just general daylight and for many
we probably already have one but you may
have like a dash mount for your phone
boom that's a YouTube short start Simple
Start in your car I've learned that
complexity is the enemy of execution